hey y'all is that Christian c-in-c
coming at you with that new hotness a
video reply to sunshine 247 who says my
conditioner does not work for her hair
congratulations you are the only human
being on earth who here doesn't like
coconut oil I mean the fact that you
will rather choose a low as a
moisturizer says it all
coconut oil is better than a low
this is a video reply to my video
applied at sunshine two four seven a lot
of my subscribers actually prefer a low
over coconut oil and I must say that I
don't know why and I think you all are
wrong and why we reddit what in the
eternal hail its sunshine two four seven
you don't want to sleep your reverse
vampire
you go around seeking blood into people
you sicko
I just try Allah it's the best substance
I have ever used on my hair I have
converted Thank You sunshine two four
seven this has been Christie is he
saying don't I look good I know that I
do